I absolutely despise working from home
because I think it's the devil a lot of
people hide behind working from home you
know I do a lot of meetings I'm out the
office a lot but I'm not working from
home you know I cover UK wide so I can
go to meetings Here There and Everywhere
but it's difficult because I think a lot
of people see it they come into the
business and it's like do you do
flexible working people want to come
into interviews thinking can I have
three days off because that's how they
see it and it might be old-fashioned but
I think the culture when people work
from home is it's like for me if I'm in
the office I'm bouncing ideas off people
I'm like what you think of this and I do
more when I'm around more people